monsieur le président aliev mais c'est
le président vous teach mesdames et
messieurs chers collègues chers amis
tout d'abord je voudrais remercier le
président de l'azerbaïdjan et le
président de la serbie pour avoir
accueilli cette réunion commémorative
et je voudrais également exprimer la
reconnaissance à tous les membres du
mouvement des non alignés qui honte
accordé ce statut à la russie a le
statut d'observateur
j'ai l'honneur de donner la lecture du
message de bienvenue du président
vladimir poutine âge
j'adresse mes cordiales salutations à
l'occasion de l'ouverture de la réunion
commémorative de haut niveau organisée à
l'occasion du 60e anniversaire du
mouvement des non alignés
ce mouvement des non alignés joue un
rôle très important dans les domaines
des affaires internationales elle a
toujours défendu les principes de
l'égalité inconditionnelle de tous les
états du respect de leur souveraineté et
de leurs droits fondamentaux
elle prône un dialogue multilatéral
constructive dans le strict respect de
l'esprit de la lettre de la charte des
nations unies
aujourd'hui la situation mondiale
devient de plus en plus turbulente et
l'humanité doit faire face à un nombre
croissant de menaces et de défis et le
potentiel positif du mouvement est
particulièrement sollicité cette
structure représentative participe
activement au règlement des situations
de crise et contribuer de manière
substantielle
dans l'instauration du monde plus
démocratique et plus stable
renforce la confiance et la
compréhension mutuelle entre les membres
de la communauté internationale mon pays
a récemment obtenu le statut
d'observateur au sein de ce mouvement et
cela ouvre sans aucun doute de nouvelles
possibilités pour la coopération dans le
traitement des questions d'actualité
pour garantir
la sécurité et le développement durable
dans le monde souhaite sincèrement un
travail fructueux est trop élevé de
réussite la lumière poutine
chers collègues j'espère que ce sommet à
l'instar du sommet de 60,1 enverra le
message clair à la plupart des pays du
monde qu'il n'y a pas d'alternative à la
construction d'une communication entre
les états sur les principes d'égalité et
compris dans l'intérêt de solutions
efficaces à de nombreux problèmes de
notre temps le nude jouant le rôle
central dans cette coordination la
russie comme l'écrasante majorité de la
communauté internationale considère que
les attaques en cours à contre la charte
de l'onu sont destructrices et
dangereuse et l'envoi de même des
tentatives de remplacer larchitecture
unis centric par des concepts non
inclusive tels que l'ordre d'y fonder
sur des règles qui repose en fait sur
des nombreux deux poids deux mesures et
risque de nous ramener à l'ère de la
politique des blocs et des lignes de
démarcation je suis convaincu que ce
mouvement par ses actions de solidarité
est capable de résister avec succès à de
telles tentatives 1
cette coopération de la russie avec les
membres de ce mouvement y compris sur la
plateforme de l'onu
confirme
l'harmonie de nos actions avec les
actions de ce mouvement et nous espérons
que notre travail commun et le niveau de
soutien mutuel des initiatives se revend
seront notamment en raison de
l'obtention du statut d'observateur de
la russie et de la coordination pour
défendre les droits du droit
international la démocratie et les
relations internationales merci de votre
attention
cinq ministres of this time to dance
with mr luc chartrou minister for any
fait aux républiques offshore qui sont
restés chez guess quand je représente
est elle s'est quand même un petit
meeting à donner votre ministère irish
ce qui faisait notre mister charles
bouchard nous lis